salve youtubers e benvenuti ad una nuova
recensione
come accennato nell'ultimo video oggi
parlerò di un'altra perla con
protagonista spider man e per farlo
dobbiamo spostarci nel giappone degli
anni settanta confusi non temete la
situazione peggiorerà nel 1978 è stata
fatta una serie live action dell'uomo
ragno ambientata in giappone chiamata su
faida man creata dalla toei conta 41
episodi e un lungometraggio quello che
vedremo insieme sarà il primissimo
episodio e credetemi quando vi dico che
ogni aspettativa che avevo su questa
serie è stata demolita in senso positivo
ovviamente guardarla è stato un po come
baciare per la prima volta o fare
l'amore per la prima volta può andare su
chatroulette per la prima volta ma
quelle open e te lo immagini in un modo
e invece in tutt'altro questa è la
recensione di sup aida man
[Musica]
l'episodio inizia con la sigla che
trasuda anni 70 da ogni poro
[Musica]
subito dopo vediamo due occhi nella
nebbia a cercare il proprio fratello
[Musica]
e poi il delirio viene inquadrato
un'astronave con dentro una donna e un
cyborg
[Musica]
fatemelo ripetere viene inquadrato
un'astronave con dentro una donna e un
cyborg e strana come cosa ma questi sono
giapponesi
se noi siamo gli italiani tutti
spaghetti e mandolino
loro sono gli stessi che hanno creato
una pubblicità con cappuccetto rosso che
balla insieme a degli animali ed un
procione con dei testicoli giganti non
mi stupisco più di nulla ma facciamo la
conoscenza del peter parker nipponico il
nostro timido secchioni di periferia
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ria sì qui è un figo ed è un
motociclista
ok nel frattempo un'altra astronave si
schianta sulla terra e peter sente delle
voci i due manigoldi di prima
hanno paura che questa astronave possa
essere trovata dal professor egli ama
giraud ed usata contro di loro quindi
decidono di ucciderlo perché sono i
cattivi se dal costume non l'avevate
capito quindi la donna si traveste da
militare e si infiltra nel laboratorio e
dopo at the next five mentre aggiusta la
moto vede l'ombra di un ragno sulla
parete e continua a sentire delle voci
[Musica]
[Applauso]
intanto gli scienziati e la donna
infiltrata cercano l'astronave
[Musica]
e lo sapevo non volevo dirlo ma mi avete
costretto quindi sigla
[Musica]
basta
mentre peter e e in moto con il
fratellino vede finalmente il ram
schermo troppo troppo troppo vigile
all'inquadratura sono aracnofobia con mi
volete far morire e niente sono
costretta a sostituire le immagini del
ragno con foto di gattini pucciosi molto
meglio
spinto da questa voce misteriosa parte
verso il gruppo di scienziati e scopre
che il padre è morto
[Musica]
neanche il tempo di versare due lacrime
viene attaccato dai c cari della donna
delle calzamaglie grigie con il becco e
gli occhiali da sole viene ferito al
collo e scappando precipita in una
grotta qui dentro finalmente diamo un
volto alla voce misteriosa un alieno
arrivato dal pianeta spider giustamente
che gli svela il piano di invasione
della terra da parte del malvagio
professor monster giustamente spiderman
sta per morire e l'alieno per salvarlo
gli infila un mega braccialetto che lo
infilza con dell'estratto di ragno
[Musica]
[Applauso]
quante cose a caso sono successe tutte
insieme
un'invasione aliena un'astronave che si
schianta un mostro dinosauro una grotta
con un tizio strambo un bracciale ragno
salvavita
e poi c'era la marmotta che confezionava
la cioccolata e si certo
e sapete cosa mi piace
ero stufo di risentire per la
quarantesima volta la stessa identica
storia dell'uomo ragno li avevo piene le
scatole
anche lo stesso zio beh si è rotto le
palle di morire per l'ennesima volta
detersivi sveglia e l'alieno gli spiega
un paio di cosette è rimasto nella
grotta per 400 anni
aspettando il momento per vendicarsi
contro il professor monster ed ha scelto
bitter per farlo perché ma è ovvio
perché altrimenti la trama non va avanti
finito il monologo la linea cade a terra
e muore scomparendo lasciando al suo
posto un ragno che hai davanti a te non
olio può far dichiarare
no è morto obi wan tornato a casa il
ragno gli dice di infilarsi il costume
[Musica]
questo è uno di quei momenti ma l'ho
visto davvero ho i miei occhi hanno
avuto un infarto
il costume viene sparato fuori dal
braccialetto si spiaccica per un secondo
addosso a peter e con una sola zip se lo
infila ed è pronto a combattere questa
cosa è fantastica ma non solo su faida
ma mica spara ragnatele di coma che
spara vere e proprie corde e con il suo
senso di ragno disegnato sulla pellicola
parte all'azione
mi aspettavo peggio le scene sui muri
devo dire
[Applauso]
[Musica]
si arrampica sulla diga e raggiunge la
base dei nemici dove tengono richiuso
uno scienziato
[Musica]
tutta questa parte è piena zeppa di
inquadrature
come dire del cazzo
no
ma perché facevano avanti e indietro
[Musica]
non c'è motivo di ripeterla
sta roba è malata tra l'altro non so voi
ma mi sta venendo una voglia stranissima
di guardarmi takeshi's castle la donna
cattiva evoca di nuovo il coccodrillo né
che diventa gigante spy di tenta di
catturarlo con le sue corde ma viene
sbattuto contro le rocce
mammamia guardate la maestosità di
questa scena un mega mostro sullo sfondo
e spider man che lotta con delle anatre
se me lo avessero raccontato gli avrei
riso in faccia
intanto dall'astronave esce
un'automobile che vola e spara missili
ecco da cosa erano tratti quei
giocattoli farlo chimiche trovavo quando
ero piccolo al mercato ora ne voglio uno
con l'auto l'uomo ragno arriva dentro
l'astronave e
[Musica]
[Applauso]
mai
[Musica]
quello è un mega zorz quello è un mega
ford non riesco a trattenere la [ __ ]
c.de a chi altro che supereroi con
superproblemi la risposta è un cazzo di
mega zorb qualsiasi cosa sarebbe meglio
come un mega sword qualsiasi tranne
grey's anatomy ma tutto il resto sì e
questo è un fatto
si sparano per un po finché il mega zorz
tira fuori una spada e lo trafigge fine
[Musica]
[Applauso]
botta
[Musica]
quindi questo era su faida man lo spider
man giapponese
se non si fosse capito orlo adorato dal
primo all'ultimo minuto
ovvio la trama non c'entra assolutamente
nulla con quella dell'uomo ragno vero e
proprio ma come intrattenimento non ha
pari io come al solito vi ringrazio in
tutti gli iscritti tutti i commenti
tutti i complimenti che mi fate tutto il
supporto infinito e ci vediamo ad una
prossima recensione che siccome le
ultime due erano su qualcosa di
divertente mi toccherà a farla su
qualcosa di terribile
no non quello anche se mio dio l'orrore